Hello Everybody
my name is Markiplier
and welcome to "Buried Beneath".
now, th-this is just a Demo
like most of these Indie Horror games are
but this one...
Is absurdly highly reviewed
And I don't know that''s-it's because it  just came out recently.
Or if, there's actually, something to this,
*Grave Tone* terrifying game
*Return to normal* Although whether it's terrifying or not I will leave up to my own judgement.
Well!
Faulty wirring it's always a good start in these horror games...
Woah (noise in the distance)
Is that..
(The noise transforms into a Moan)
Hiii (Mildly Startled)
It's that the Moose Man?
Cause I haven't the Moose Man's call, in many a year.
I don't know what my...
Mouse just ran over.
oh...
yeah... Something is over there!
something is over dere!
Can I...
do something about-
Nope.
Ok, i can't take a seat.
*Surprised Markimoo*
I didn't even know that was there!
That was just a guess.
What...
Can I hide in here?
Do I need to hide?
*WHOOSH OF SATAN*
OHH
AYAAAAAWAAYAOOO
AYYYOUUYOOO
Heyyyyyyy
I-I decided to stretch a bit
it's a good time! I wanted to warm up
before this.
Game got underway
Anyway, did something happen?
wow, where did I go?
I think I got turned around
but I'm not sure...
*Nervous chuckle*
ahh-oook
we're off to a
"Voluptuous" start
ok, it's that supposed to be a indication of danger, or where I'm supposed to go.
and how urgently i am supposed to go there?
*Starts to say something but stops* I should follow the trail
Haaah- let me stop myself
and follow down the arrow that i thought I was gonna need to go down
mm-k
so what else have you got for me? (Careful at what you ask)
In terms of the cheap Jump-scare
Realm of possibility.
seem to be in an old Communist Bunker. *OH REALLY?*
But what does that mean for meeeee?
And also, why?
And how?
*Wild nope appears*
Ohh hiiiiIIIIIII
*You tried to run away*
OOOOooookkkkkk
What the fuck was that?!
Oh it's- *You can't escape*
Gyaaaeeeeehhhh
Ihhhhh
it's so goopy!
agghhh
it's goopy!
why is it goopy?
it was so goopy!
it's that what popped up before?
*Wild Nope uses screech!*
It's seems to be angry at something.
Probably me for disturbing it's beauty sleep.
*Ominous noise as Mark realizes what he got himself into*
Ok...
That's not a good sound...
*Wild Nope used Headbutt!*
ehhh-woooah
It's still coming, I didn't even know it was-be coming after me
Fuck o---OOOOOO
Fuck off, dude.
he is getting, close.
he's getting WAY to close.
agghhh
What-I-I couldn't read dat.
The door's jammed I should...
Get a crow bar?
I don't know where a fucking crow bar is
*Mumbles* I think I'm screw-ooh
*Weird Noises, or moans, if you hae enough imagination*
*Markimoo worried noise* I don't know where a crow bar is
I barrely found a flash light.
and that was by pure chance.
where the fuck I am going to find a crow bar?
do I gotta go back, somehow?
ooohh- I gotta go back don't I?
I don't know where a god-damn crow bar is!
That thing is gonna GET me.
I don't know what it's gonna do to me when it gets me but it's gonna get me!
*We all know what it'll do ; )*
It's got goopy-neck tentacles.
(Moans aproaching)
uhhh
AAAgggghhh
What are you doing? What are you doing?
huh?
What are you doin'?
You wanna fight?
Huh?!
Put em' up! *DOUBLE MIDDLE FINGER DEFENSE ACTIVATE
Fuck you!
*Noise of death and destruction*
Well then
agghhh I guess I fucked it, didn't i?
God-dammit I don't know where the...
god-damn crow bar is.
ok, so what I am gonna do, is I'm gonna go back through this and I'm gonna try to find the crow bar
before hand, and then not get scared by the jump-scare.
*Jumpcut*
Ok so, it's not in any of this so I am willi-oohh
I am willing to bet
that the crow bar is in this room that the guy is in right now.
The only problem with that.
is that I don't know how to get down here
without him coming to kill me.
you know what I mean, because this very narrow hallways
and there is not a lot of room to get away.
so-but I bet
I bet, I'd be willing to bet money
that-that's exactly where it is
and I believe
I might be able to lose him on these stairs
and then going around that way.
But we shall see.
I don't know if it's going to be enough space though
because it's not a lot of room to run
but if I need it
I've got it
At least I know what was buried beneath
*Kill me*
*Markifart mating call*
*Mating call continues but to no avail*
Just trying to out-moan him
*It's not going to work Mark...*
Hey Buba.(At the game)
heyyy Buba (...)
Heeyyyy
hey buba
Buba!
BUBA!
*Mark slowly goes insane*
Bababababababa
Baba!
hey Baba
*Some sort of alternate mating call*
Babah(Disapointed)
god--damnit baba
uhhhhgh
ohoh
uhhhhhh- Buba found me
k- so if I go up here
I might be able to swing swong around.
quick enough.
before he can get me and then get down and then run
and then getting out is going to be another problem.
uh
oh
he didn't see me
whattt?
he didn't see me.
Did he go back down?
*Markiplier shows off his impressive IQ of -999*
AGGHHHH
Wohooo!(Leaning back)
Weeeiii-Fuck Y-(Dead)
God-damnit I was-NNAAAAhhhhAHAH
AAAhhhhh
fuck
*Jumpcut* Hidey hidey hidey ho
Hi
ok, there he is.
Ugh
eagh, you're so gross
Eaaghhh
so big too
Why's he so big and bulbous? *Big word Mark!*
is he actually gonna come up here this time?
God-dammit
He's guarding it
Ok, maybe I've gotta go over here and trigger the...
The "Ohh, I need a crow bar" dialog and then... *Mark rambles on for a bit to fill the video*
ok, so.
The door's jammed, I should find a crow bar somewhere.
so I can get back now, before, it cuts me off.
Hey-Hey- hey-hhhuuuaaahh
Ohhh-nooh.
oh-oh
that did not go the way that i wanted it to go.
shiett
fuck
*Mark panic*
Oh dammit
Ok, I'm good.
Ohh
No, not good yet.
*Ghost impression*
Shit
(More shit)
Ok
that's right, you better back off buddy bu
Buba-buba
(More Buba)
Full of trubba'
I'm gonna go for it-ggghhhh
I don't think he noticed, I don't think he noticed, I don't think he noticed
Ok, so
It's gotta be in here somewhere, right?
It's the only logical place for a crow-ber
*Poor Life Choices*
Ohh shit
It's not down here.
fuck
Wher-where is the crow-ber?
*Jumpcup*
Oooohhh, ok.
ok, so
I actually had to look this up
The fuck?
why can't I...
ohh, boy.
Ok, there we go.
G-ok
So I had to look this up...
uh-oh
sound bad
How close is he?
*Panic! at the Markifart* He's right nearby, ooohhhh ok
where was he?
ok, so I had to look that up
there are actually keys
in there, and I don't know how I missed it
because I figured there would be something in that room where he spawned in
but there are keys down there
and the keys open a door that then leads to the crow bar
Now I don't know how anyone would've been...
expected to understand that.
Oh, where is he? He's around here somewhere
*Chewbacca-plier*
god-dammit you're blocking my path Buba!
c'mon, hurry up, move along.
you're already dead, you're just a floating head.
*Buba wants a hug*
ueehh-ogh Jesusm, he heard me insulting him
he didn't like that very much.
ok, so he's coming.
I'm gonna slip by him
Come up here
Come up ere
Come up 'ere
Come up 'ere my g-Ohhhh
Oh fuck, god-dammit
that's not how I wanted that to go.
I keep missing those stairs.
But at least he stopped...
(Weird Noises)
Ok
I think he went down stairs
Ohhh
(OWL)
(Even more Owl)
YeeaAAhhh
YeAh, buddy
yeaaahh, buddy
Ok.So the- yeah here!
so...
Now this opens, it didn't even have dialog or anything like that
And somewhere in'ere
There's a Cr-There it is
A crow ber
Cr-Crow Baer
Crow Ber
There we go
Cru Barb
oh it's like Half-Life®
except instead of holding it
I'm picking it up in front of me with the Gravity Gun®
But anyway-OK
Crow Ber
Yeaahhh-Crow Ber
not exactly how you-you use a crow bar in that situation
Egh
Ok, good, yes.
We're Free
Maybe?
Are we- are we free?
we don't-We don't-we don't
we don't seem very free
Are we-are we...
Ohhhhh The Big Lever
Yes
No?
Maybe so?
N-Noh?
O-Ohh
(A poem by Marky-Seuss)
I had to click on the actual device and not the lever
*Look at poor little confused Markifart*
Ok so what did that do?
What did that do?!
Wait-What?
Did that...
*BUBA SUMMONS SATAN*
(Time for some stretches)
All right, it'zgodda do my last stretches you know final stretches for the end of the game
Ok, so that was, interesting.
Not perfect
But still it got me good on some certain areas
Mostly just from jumpscares
But-Even-even so, it was still pretty good
And what is even more amazing is,
I am not sure if this is true.
I-I read somewhere that the developer of this game.
Is 13 years old.
I don't know if that's true, that's just what I heard that might have been someone in the comments trying to insult the developer
I have no idea, but it was highly rated.
and actually gon-Let me-Let me confirm this before I start spouting about that...
Ok, yes.
It said in the description
that the game on Game-Joint
This was made by someone who is 13 years old.
and
No matter what way you slice it, that's pretty impresive
someone who is 13 is already starting
and making games.
And this is put together, it's not perfect, it's not polished
but it's put together, and
it's pretty interesting.
like not terribly interesting, mind you.
but it's got some potential there.
and it's even more impressive that the-the developer is so young.
So
take that for what you will, I find it very impressive
and I like this game a lot.
so let's me you know what you thought  on th-down the comments bellow
give the developers some support and encoragement for making more stuff in the future.
and in a few years who knows what they'll make.
So thank you so much for watching.
and as always i'll see you in the next video.
Bye byeee
(Haunted, by: Shirk)